on march 4 a giant container ship named
the ever given left the port of ningbo
china
which is just south of shanghai the ever
given flies under the flag of panama
but it's owned by the evergreen marine
corporation a really big taiwanese
container transportation and shipping
company
evergreen owns 39 of these vessels with
20 of them named in this format of ever
plus a word that starts with the letter
g like these
in the case of this ship it's longer
than not only aircraft carriers but is
even longer than the empire state
building is tall
and weighs in at 200 metric tons and
over the next week
the ever given would go down the asian
continent making stops at taipei in
taiwan
then further down to yangshan china
which is next to hong kong
then all the way down to a port in
malaysia from there it would start its
10-day journey out at sea
all the way to the gulf of aden at the
horn of africa then
up the red sea all the way to the suez
port at the south end of the suez canal
on march 22
the suez canal is one of the most
important trade routes in the world
march 23rd 3 11 am local time
the ever given is outside the suez canal
waiting for his turn to travel through
it
while waiting for around the next three
hours the ever given sailed in a
unique path that resembled
well take a look for yourself
this pap was tracked by the website
vesselfinder.com when asked about this
they were adamant that the ship's
tracking data was accurate
and that there is no room for some kind
of conspiracies or false data
did the captain of the ship draw this
path on purpose
who knows there were reports of strong
wind and dust storms in this area around
the same time
and it took three hours to sail this
path so if this was done on purpose
he must have been very dedicated to
create this image
after completing that wonderful drawing
at around 7 15 am local time
the ever given entered into the south
entrance of the suez canal
four kilometers into the canal and
everything is normal
but then things get a little squirrely 7
35 am
the vessel starts wobbling right to left
two minutes later at 7 37 a.m
the vessel stops wobbling but finds
himself making a hard left
one minute later 7 30 8 am every given
is on the verge of slamming against the
left side of the canal
so the ship counters with a hard right
setting it on a path back to the center
of the canal
one minute later at 7 39 am things seem
back on track
but the ship doesn't seem to be
straining out and by 7
42 am the evergreen has reached the
point of no return and isn't able to
stop turning right
and it ramps into the eastern barge of
the canal its sheer momentum leaves the
rear of the ship swinging up
and it takes an entire two agonizing
minutes for the rear of the behemoth to
collide with the other side of the canal
and the suez canal was left at a
standstill now when you have 200
000 metric tons moving at a few miles an
hour that's an incredible amount of
momentum
of energy and so it when it lodges in
the side that's you know it's lodged in
there the suez canal is the connecting
link between two giant economies
europe and asia that allow ships to not
have to sail all the way around africa
which adds around two weeks to their
trips
which is why the suez can now account
for 12 percent of global trade
nearly a third of global container ship
traffic with 52 ships passing through it
every day
valued at 9.6 billion dollars a day but
in the span of just seven minutes
one of the most important trade routes
is shut down 12 percent of global trade
grinds to a halt
at the cost of 400 million dollars every
hour the great news is that you don't
have to build something massive like the
suez canal to make a lot of money
that's where trends comes in trends
makes finding the next big thing
easy with a trend membership you can
browse thousands of vetted business
ideas you can launch in no time
thanks to a helpful community of
like-minded hustlers there are too many
trends success stories to cite
but i personally enjoyed reading about
craig's nerdy nuts when craig joined
trends
he asked for honest feedback and got
roasted like even more roasted than his
own peanuts kind of roasted
but like all good entrepreneurs he
listened and pivoted
and thanks to the advice of the trans
community nerdiness is now a million
dollar a year company
and is even being hailed as a ben
jerry's a peanut butter how nuts is that
that was a horrible joke stick to the
end to learn more or stop what you're
doing right now
pause the video and get your first week
of transfer just one dollar by going to
trends.co
jake tran right now the link is on the
screen and in the video description
below
initially they estimated that it would
take around a week to get the ship out
but that estimation quickly grew to at
least a few weeks
and the traffic jam grew at one point
over 350 vessels were caught in the
traffic jam
all of which had this stuff on board
some ships had to quickly resort to
taking the long trip around africa
adding around 15 000 miles and two weeks
to their journey
and as with anything the biggest
problems in the world
make for the greatest memes so the
natural question is
what made the ship crash at first the
crash was blamed on bad weather
it was windy there was a dust storm that
killed visibility which may very well be
the cause
but by day 5 authorities said strong
winds and weather factors were not
the main reasons for the ship's
grounding there may have been technical
or human errors
people also started to say that there
was a power outage on the ship
and since giant ships need power
steering once the power cut
off the ship was left rudderless the
ship goes into the suez canal and it had
a blackout its power went out and so it
just kept cruising without being able to
control the steering because there's
like friggin power steering on these
massive ships
you know like they don't have like a
wire connected to the rudder and now
they think it's going to take another
week or two before they'll be able to
kind of dig all around the sand and
tugboat the thing out of there
but until we get some clearer answers
one thing is clear
the balance of the world can flip within
minutes a small
power outage on a boat on a ship you
know
in the middle of um of the suez canal
can suddenly block up
so much of global trade and cause you
know massive fluctuations and commodity
prices and availability of supplies and
products for businesses around the world
there's going to be rippling economic
effects
shipping used to be very complicated and
expensive before standardized containers
since pallets and crates were all
different sizes
and made things very labor intensive and
inefficient and it didn't make sense to
ship most things overseas
but by the 1970s the 20-foot shipping
container became the standard
and from that point on the world economy
was forever changed
ports became way more efficient as
containers were adopted and the cost to
ship goods shot way down
with modern ports being able to move
around 70 containers per
crane per hour no longer didn't matter
where you produced things because
transport costs became irrelevant
and that's why this was the point where
production began to migrate elsewhere to
countries with cheaper labor
with the epicenter being china and since
then the number of containers moved
around the world has increased almost
every year since 2000.
or in other words shipping containers
have become the main part of the
lifeblood of the modern economy
and with the pandemic already putting
strain on shipping a new rental stimulus
checks out
the suez canal crash happened at the
worst possible time
[Music]
[Applause]
since the suez can now mainly connects
europe and asia initially there were a
lot of fears that it would disrupt the
global supply chain
from everyday goods you can buy in the
store to oil this could range from
toilet paper
coffee furniture gas and with a new
round of stimulus checks
people have more money to spend on what
could potentially be a delayed supply
but by day 7 the ship was finally freed
and even if it wasn't freed for a while
it probably wouldn't have been that bad
because at the end of the day
it is still only twelve percent of
global trade which is a lot but not the
end of the world
and ships can always sail around africa
in the meantime at the cost of an extra
two weeks and maybe pirates
as some of them started doing but what
you should worry about is just how
fragile our delicate world really is
but i think what's interesting so 10 of
global trade moved through the suez
canal
and about 100 of these massive ships a
day moved through this canal
but it really highlights the fragility
of our global supply chain
similar to kind of the experience i
think we had during the covet pandemic
when all of a sudden
since the start of the industrial
revolution and it really dates back to
the agricultural revolution
everything in society has only gotten
more concentrated more centralized
we went from nomadic tribes spread out
across the land to centralized
civilizations centered around farming
centralized farming villages evolved
into even more centralized cities
factories and governments
which leads us to today where we've
optimized everything to be the lowest
cost
possible but at the expense of any
robustness in our global economy
where one random dust storm or power
outage can cause our global trade to
drop over 10
in a matter of minutes where one bad
storm could cause a state's centralized
power grid to shut down in the middle of
winter
where one pandemic can destroy the ppe
and pharmaceutical supply chain
the global industrial revolutions were
really predicated on this notion of
centralization but the problem
with centralization generally speaking
in supply chains is exactly this which
is you you have a supply chain that is
much more delicate
it is much more i mean think about the
difference in power right if the power
goes out at a power plant
all the homes that are connected to it
lose power versus if every home had
their own power generator or solar cells
they could continue to support
themselves
the world as it stands is very fragile
and when you look at it through this
lens
isn't it just amazing that we've somehow
not only survived but
thrived this long without blowing
ourselves up
it's incredible so hopefully an event
like this wakes us up to the need to
decentralize
and i'm not just talking about
blockchain but for us to become more
robust in every part of our world
from the digital to the physical so much
of our global supply chain for industry
has become centralized by finding the
lowest cost possible
but it loses all of its durability we
were so concerned about
short-term profit maximization that we
offshored our entire
pharmaceutical production and ppe
manufacturing
to china which then said that they might
ration it to us based on
you know geopolitical concerns no thank
you so yeah that is pennywise and pound
foolish
the absolute definition is the is the
infrastructure
huge problems like this in the world
mean huge business opportunities for you
to capitalize on
that's where trends comes in as a trans
member you'll receive alerts called
signals about up-and-coming business
trends months or even years before they
become mainstream news
this is my favorite part of trends
because it spares you the feeling of
regret of not knowing about the next big
thing sooner
which is a feeling that i know all too
well as a subscriber
you'll also get private access to the
super helpful community of makers
enabling you to network and collaborate
with over 15 000 ambitious and
successful people
all rooting for your success like this
guy who found a number of great angel
investors through trends
and says that trent has paid for his
membership fee back 100x
the next big wave is on the horizon
don't miss it
so stop what you're doing right now
pause the video and get your first week
of transfer just one dollar by going to
trends.co
jake trend right now the link is on the
screen and in the video description
below
there's no commitment no catch and you
can cancel anytime again that's
trends.co
jake tran with the link below
[Music]
welcome to the watch the end club it's
been a really long time since i've said
that the podcast you saw throughout this
video is called the all in podcast it's
one of the only podcasts that i really
enjoy listening to
they're at like 65k subs so they're
definitely a hidden gem on youtube and i
will link it below for you guys to check
out
and let's help them get to 100k let them
know that i sent you in the comments
section if you are new here we make
video essays just like this one every
single week on the most provocative
thought-provoking stuff in the world of
business so you might as well subscribe
because it's free and you can always
dislike unsubscribe and leave me your
best hate comments in the comments below
all the memes i shared in this video i
share them in real time when i find them
on my instagram we have a great time
over there so if you want more business
memes
and world event memes you can follow me
at jaketrend.io link below anyways
that's going to wrap up this video you
guys thank you so much for watching
you've been awesome i've been jake stay
dangerous out there and i will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
you